thought about how insane submarines are
no well I do I think about this all the
time I'm not talking about these cute
little science explorers I'm talking
about these massive military nuclear
attack submarines these windowless
spaceships of the ocean strapped with
ballistic missiles that have nuclear
warheads on them these things travel
underwater in stealth mode or complete
darkness for months at a time they move
slowly to avoid making noise so they
won't be detected by enemies they're
even coated with rubbery tile that
absorbs sound so that sonar can't bounce
up against them so the question I always
have is like don't they run into things
like whales or something it turns out
they don't I mean most of the time they
don't they put out sound into the ocean
and whatever bounces off gives them a
map of what is ahead of them it also
Maps look at these beautiful maps of the
ocean floor but sometimes they're wrong
in 2005 this submarine ran into an
underground Mountain because of an error
in one of their Maps well regardless I
would rather take my chance out there on
the ocean submarines are really freaking
cool